my story starts in the northern
Galapagos Islands under 50 feet of water
and a big school of sharks I'd been
scuba diving with a group of friends for
about a week and had been glorious manta
rays whale sharks penguins and of course
hammerhead sharks today's dive was
particularly tricky the surge was
terrible you had to have your camera rig
tight in and your arm out cuz the surge
kept throwing you into the rocks while
you're scanning up for that beautiful
photograph it was going okay until not
okay something was terribly terribly
wrong I pulled my hand back and I had
long black sea urchin spines all the way
through my gloves which meant all the
way through my hand now this is bad
I mean obviously when you have something
all the way through your hand it's kind
of bad anyway but in this case sea
urchins have a venom on them that if
you've ever tangled with them you know
that a sea urchin spine and you gives
you horrible painful inflammation but
that wasn't even taught most in my mind
at this point this did not look real I
could not believe that this was my hand
now in a crisis I tend to disassociate
into like little scientists and I start
talking very analytically all analysis
was gone adrenaline brain kicked in and
I just yanked the spines out I don't
remember doing it I just remember
thinking I can't get my glove off with
these in here
I do remember taking the glove off in a
big plume of black coming up in front of
my face and biologists brain now shows
up and starts freaking out how could all
that toxin have gotten into that wound
already well physicist brain then shows
up and very calmly explains no no no
we're at 50 feet red wavelengths are
attenuated that's blood not black and
sharks
so what are you gonna do well I cranked
my cummerbund down really hard over my
hand and I simply swam away let's that
big old cloud of blood dissipate a bit
before we have to surface through all of
these sharks so when I did surface my
warm blooded mammal brain was in an
absolute gibbering panic they don't feed
when they're schooling they don't feed
when they're schooling all the way up
and they didn't so apparently they have
read the same books that I have now it
turns out when you've been stabbed with
sea urchin spines and you're two days
away from any medical help the thing
that you've got to do is unfortunately
cook your hand so you put it in water as
hot as you can stand and you keep adding
boiling water until you think you'll go
absolutely insane now it worked the hand
itself did not work so well for several
weeks after that but eventually fine
motor skills returned all except for one
spot that stayed stiff and painful for
weeks after the other things had gotten
better so it turned out I'd broken off a
tip of the urgent spine in the joint
itself and that's why it wasn't getting
better and so the orthopedist says you
know we should get this out nothing to
urgent not emergency so we scheduled a
small surgery for a few weeks out on a
Monday and on the Friday before I broke
my pelvis in a horseback riding accident
yeah so we kind of postponed that
surgery my broken pelvis and I were now
facing six weeks on the couch and I
would have gone absolutely insane if it
hadn't been for my friends spontaneous
parties broke out at my house every
night for weeks I was fed I was
entertained it was great but that kind
of enthusiasm is sort of hard to sustain
over the long term and eventually it
petered down to just one friend who
would send me jokes during the day and
come and keep me company in the evenings
someone I got to know a whole lot better
during this period of convalescent
and when I was finally pronounced well
enough to do weight-bearing activities
we loaded a telescope and the car drove
up into the mountains to look at the
hale-bopp comet yes
we're geeks and got caught in a
landslide I know like really no just
kidding
no more disasters no just the opposite
in fact that was 21 years ago and for 19
of those years I have been married to
that marvelous introvert who never in a
million years would have approached me
under other circumstances we have a
wonderful fourteen-year-old daughter who
did all my illustrations yeah so protip
apparently nothing makes you sexier than
needing a walker on your first date so
this isn't a story about piercings or
sharks or boiling Zoar breakings it's a
love story it's a love story with a
funny little epilogue
now I was weight bearing again I could
reschedule that surgery get the spine
out but I didn't need it anymore turns
out when you break a bone your body
scavenges calcium from all the bones in
your body and from the little sea urchin
spine that you happen to have lodged in
the joint of your finger so yes my
pelvis is now part C urchin so to
biology brain physicist brain adrenaline
brain warm blooded mammal brain I get to
add virgin brain with all of these
superpowers that that confers so you
don't need to worry though that I am NOT
fully human is one of the things that my
family loves the most about me thank you
very much
[Applause]